When you say for people to prepare what
they want to say before they say it, I
have had issues where I would prepare so
much in my mind that I would play out
the whole situation and then I'd be
like, you know what? I'm not even going
to talk. Yeah.
>> You know, I mean I've already had the
conversation in my head. I'm like, I say
this and then they say this and then I
say this and then I do this and then
we're back to this place and they didn't
even know that I had the whole thing.
So, how can the people prepare for
conversations but not
create a scenario where they're
affirming stories in their head about
the relationship and they're allowing
breathing room and space for a different
texture to arise. So, it's like if in
our relationship instead of being like,
he always does this, he never listens to
me, he never does that. If I say this,
he's going to say that. How can I be
like, I want to prepare what I'm going
to say but I also want to create a space
where
I'm not over preparing so that you can
show up differently. Yeah, so what you
do is you prime the conversation.
>> Okay. And this is how you do it. You're
going to tell the person I have
something I want to share but it's not
fully thought out or I'm nervous about
sharing this or this is going to sound
confusing or this might jump around. You
are tell you're being vulnerable in this
moment. When you can say, I'm nervous to
share this with you
or would you just listen anyway? And
they're going to say yes. That's what's
going to happen. Um cuz if they don't
then
they're a jerk. I mean I'm sorry. If if
I'm like, I'm nervous to share something
important with you
>> I find a man that says yes.
>> Yeah. I mean but the thing is you're
you're if nobody's going to say
they're just not going to
particularly in a romantic relationship
and when you can say, this is not fully
thought out
I'd like to say this to you or I need to
I need to say this. This is what's on my
chest, what's on my heart, what's in my
head. Uh what I'll often leave with is,
I don't know where this is going. I just
need it out of my head. Love it. And so
when I can start with, I'm not sure
where this is going yet but I need it
out. I need to say this out loud.
It's just letting them know it's kind of
striking that balance like you said of I
don't want to over prepare. At the same
time, I want them to know this is an
evolving conversation. Another thing you
can do, let's say in the workplace,
let's put it for anybody listening in
the workplace context, use a percentage.
So, what I mean by that is let's say you
need to throw out an idea. Mhm. People
think when you throw out an idea it has
to be a bow on it. It needs to be 100%
of an idea
and it's for them to decide to say it's
great or not. Like you give an idea for
a meeting or something and somebody
goes, "Oh, that's a terrible idea." And
you go, "Okay, well, you think of
something." Mhm. Well, use a percentage
of all right, I got 10% of an idea.
Y'all let me know on the other 90%. Or
you're I I got 30% of an idea. You're
telling them that this is not fully
thought out.
You're responsible to help me with the
other 70%. We're brainstorming here. You
can still do that even in the romantic
relationship setting. Okay, I have I
have 20% of a thought here and I'd like
to hear you on the other 80%.
>> that. And it just tells them that hey, I
I don't have everything
figured out. I I don't have all the
answers. Mhm. But I have something
that's I need to say, I need to get out
of my head and communicate with you. I
love that. It's vulnerability. It's
creating freedom. It's like inviting
someone in cuz it's I like a lot of what
you teach is like getting buy-in from
the other person. It's like having them
be a participant and engaged because
I think that changes it from you just
talking at them to like we're both in
this and that brings consciousness,
awareness, connection.
>> Yeah. Um with my clients a lot of times
when we're talking about things like
I'll make just like the percentage
thing, I'll make them rank from 1 to 10.
I'm like, "Okay, how alive is that for
you right now?" Like zero to 10, you
know what I mean? Just kind of like
helping us frame of the priority of
things Yeah. and helping us figure out
where to move. Um when we talk about
women at work,
what is some advice you give for people
on giving and receiving feedback? I
think uh for me, I've gotten so much
better at it, but um there is like a
posturing that sometimes I feel like I
have to be in for feedback, where it
feels different than like normal me,
where normal me is just like and then
I'm like
let's talk. You know, it's like I feel
like I have to like shift. Right.
>> So, how do we as women give feedback
better, receive feedback better?
>> Yeah.
To give feedback better, you want to
never use the word but. So, this is what
>> But? But. Oh.
>> But.
I thought you said bud.
>> Yeah. All right.
Listen up, [laughter] bud. All right,
bud.
>> champ.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. All right, big fella.
>> [laughter]
>> Listen up. Uh yeah.
>> You know like you know it's feedback
time when you say big fella.
>> Yeah, yeah. Oh yeah, or big [laughter]
dog. Okay, big dog.
Uh
uh is the word but. Because this is how
bad feedback typically sounds. I love
all what you're doing. I think this is
really great.
Um
but what I think you could do or you
should do that that word but just
deleted everything you said before.
>> searching for the but. They're waiting
for it.
>> They're waiting for it.
>> for it. You can even hear it in their
tone. They say, "Oh, I think everything
you did was great."
And you're waiting for the but.
And all you need to do is switch that to
and. Simple as that. I love all of this.
I love all of this. And what I know
would make it even better
is if you did X, Y, and Z. So, when
you're using language that adds onto it.
So, you're building it instead of
tearing it down. Uh so, if if it can be
as simple as the I think the project is
is great and what would make it even
better is you do blah blah blah. Or what
I would have loved to have seen on it,
too, is this. When you're adding onto
it,
then it doesn't feel like you're taking
anything away. Now, you're kind of being
collaborative. Say, "I want to help you
with this." Another thought um
is to make sure that you are distancing
the,
object from the person.
So, you're
feedback goes wrong when you're
personalizing
it in a way that makes it sound like,
"Yeah, so your presentation, I didn't
think it was that great." versus
"I think the presentation could benefit
from a tweak." I'm not personalizing.
I'm now said the presentation or the
>> Instead of yours. Exactly.
>> Got it. Love that.
>> And,
now you're kind of separating
them. Now, you're not critiquing them.
Now, it's
It's the difference between I'm
addressing something towards you,
Krista, right here versus let's get that
piece of paper and put it over there.
Now, we're talking about it together.
Now, we're looking at the piece of
that piece that's a third person away
from us. Now, we're talking about it
together. Wow. For Okay, so
>> [clears throat]
>> Something and I I don't Again, I don't
know if this is me problem. So, that's
really helpful for the giving feedback.
>> Yeah. And then, receiving it. And
I think what I perceive is that when I'm
in certain states of business, that I
have to be very It's almost like I have
to be either feminine or masculine. And
like I feel like sometime I know this is
crazy.
I'm listening. I'm listening. Eyes says
eyes said it all.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, so that
sometimes in work I have to be like for
for me to be very clear and very direct
means I'm more in my masculine and it
kind of means I'm more cold
>> Yeah. and more open. Is there ways of
being where you have like a very warm,
friendly, engaging tone that's also
very direct and prescriptive? Like is
there a perfect mix of communication
that exists, do you think? I do. Okay. I
mean, there is
Yeah, you're always true.
>> could say masculine, feminine, whatever.
It's It's It's really
>> you just want It's really It's No, it's
just a desert You know, stereotypes of
what typically bad communicators do.
All right? Because it the the idea that
uh you have to be super macho of you
know, let me No, I'm not liking that.
Get out of here. Like that kind of
language is somehow more confident. No,
that's a bully It's ego-driven measuring
stick type of communication. On the end
of it, you say it's something more
feminine, you have to be extra emotional
and go, "Hey, so sorry, guys. Uh so I
was wondering if you know, and totally
told me if this is fine if you don't
like this at all." Like that kind of
stuff.
And that's the opposite, also equally
bad. Yeah. And so there is absolutely a
middle ground and
you know, what my book is going to teach
them is this idea of there is a blend of
you can equally be warm and also be
assertive. You can be kind and also be
confident. They're They're They're
They're not mutually exclusive.
I'm somebody who I try to be warm in my
communication. I'm not a cold, heartless
person. Uh I said, "Oh, I'm not." And
yeah, I'm actually crazy.
>> [laughter]
>> You're like good to have you here for an
hour. Exactly, right.
Um and at the same time
it's um this blend that you want to make
sure that it's doesn't matter if this
masculine, feminine, it's all in your
head. It mostly has to do with your tone
and your and your word choice. That's
really the difference. Is your Is your
word choice. Word choice meaning say
more.
No.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, I don't know.
So what would be examples of word
choices that would be a great mix of
both masculine and feminine that you
would suggest people use? So And then
I'll stop with the masculine, feminine.
No, you're fine. You're fine. You're
fine. So let's say anybody. Anybody if
if you want to sound This is the second
step of saying it with confidence, is
using words
>> have control. Yes, after you have
control and you control your body and
triggers, you're able to control your
yourself and see those triggers in other
people. That's the big one.
>> And judge them. Yeah. For their
triggers.
>> and judge them for their triggers. Yes.
>> for their triggers.
>> Absolutely berate them and guilt them.
Yeah.
Uh is you want to use language that's
going to serve you better. And it starts
with your assertive voice. So people
want to
What I I hear a lot of times is if I
only had the confidence to say or I'm
really building up the confidence to do
X.
But they have it wrong. Confidence is
the outcome. It's not the start.
It's you get the confidence by saying
assertive things.
>> Mhm. When you can use assertive language
you'll feel more confident. And then
with that confidence, you then have the
confidence to say more assertive things.
And they start to feed off each other.
Like when we were kids, we had no
problem saying no. No, I don't want
that. I don't like that. No, are you
Have you seen that that lunchbox? No,
absolutely. I need I need Marvel. I need
Spider-Man on my lunchbox. I don't want
that
Get that Get that stuff away. So Snoopy,
yeah, right.
>> [laughter]
>> And
you
You you had that assertive voice, you
just kind of lost it along the way and
you found ways to people please and all
that. So here's an example.
Unnecessary apologies.
Saying sorry when there's nothing you
did wrong.
Like saving sorrys for the real For
sure.
>> When you've really done something wrong.
When you've offended somebody, you've
hurt somebody, you've made that mistake.
But if it's so sorry, I'm just now
seeing this. So sorry, I'm just now
getting back to you. Oh my gosh, I'm so
sorry. I I didn't even see your text.
Like that kind of thing is why are you
apologizing for having priorities? Why
are you apologizing
for any of that? It is
Your your self-worth is not tied to how
little of an inconvenience you can be.
It's
to always be hesitant in that space is
is never going to serve you.
And so eliminating the unnecessary
apologies, instead what you do Chris is
you use words of gratitude.
Thank you for your patience. Thank you
for the giving me the time to think
about this.
That kind of thing is
not only are you giving them patience
cuz when you say thank you for your
patience they're going to think oh yeah
well I am a very patient I am a patient
person. You're welcome. You're so
welcome.
>> [laughter]
>> And it it allows you to to
come into it with a lot more
authenticity
every single time. So
big one there's lots but biggest one is
unnecessarily apologies. That's a good
one. I don't do that but it's a good
Never yeah. I stopped doing that
actually. Right. Cuz it just I don't
like when people do that to me cuz it's
like I just it makes me feel like I have
to make them feel better.
Well
>> they're like I'm sorry I'm like then I
feel a pull like oh I have to be like oh
it's okay. Right right right. Yeah it's
the same thing with is when somebody
says I hate to bother you.
And it's like now you have to have a
mini conversation
before you actually have the
conversation. You have to say like no no
no no you're not bothering me you go oh
no are you sure I'm I'm not bothering
you right now you're like no no no you
can go ahead. So what are we doing here?
Yeah yeah. Can we can you can you tell
me? Now all you're doing is saying what
I'm about to tell you is going to bother
you. Yeah. That's all you can say oh
this is going to be a dumb question and
you go no no no no in the back of your
head you're going what a dumb question.
>> I'm just thinking about man your parents
really you up.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay you said the word authentic. Yeah.
Um
And I don't know if you I'm trying to
think I mean your stuff I've seen you
talk about this. How can people show up
authentically online? Like how do you
see communication what? I'm listening
and like okay how do how What do you
mean?
>> they going to do? They're going to need
to post things that are more authentic.
I mean everything we see tons of stuff
that people post and it's just fake.
It's fake. They're not real. And so many
times you can see that the person is not
Yeah. They ever hurts me start this on a
podcast. Okay, I get this question a
million times. Everybody's asking for
this. Mhm. Nobody's asking you for it.
>> Nobody's asking you to talk about this.
>> Who is asking me about my hair? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. [laughter] Okay, guys,
everybody's been asking me where I got
this. No, nobody has.
>> going to be an ad.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Nobody's asking
Nobody's asking what this and plus it's
going to be a bad video cuz you wasted 7
seconds. So true.
>> I get this question all the time. What
are you doing? Like
Everybody just turned that off. So, it's
there's a whole lot of
just surface level facade in social
media. I get it. I understand it. It's
never going to serve you. Yeah, I'm
going to Hey, come on. Come on in the
car. You want to You want to be real? I
got to get out of the car.
>> car seats in the back, you know, with my
Sonic cup
>> [laughter]
>> my Walmart sack in the back? Yeah, come
come on.
So, yeah, if you want to show up
more authentically online,
just showing the real. Like during COVID
when everybody was home,
that's when people felt comfortable
showing the messy buns and the no
makeup. Now videos are
women putting on their makeup while
they're talking. Now it's relatable. So
true. Man, I looked horrible during the
pandemic. I thought I I thought I was
like fine. I'm like, oh, it's like okay.
And I look back, I'm like, Jesus Christ.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm like, I was Everybody Everybody was
just
>> all Everybody was messes. Yeah, but that
I think that I'm glad that happened
because it just adds
Let people be more raw with how they
really feel. You're not having to have
that polish and shine on everything. I
mean, I had a lot of doubt when I first
started my stuff on I need to look like
a a lawyer. I need to have my suit and
tie.
>> a lawyer look like?
So, like probably a old white guy. I
mean
I need to have
Yeah, I'm getting there. But I mean like
if you have your your law school books
in the back or in your in front of your
desk and you need to have a a tie on.
Yes. Oh yeah, I'd back to back telling
them Yeah, how I'm going to fight for
them. That kind of Yeah.
Yeah. And the cheese grater.
And so you were like I'm just going to
be myself.
Yeah.
I I have I'm just tired of the excuses.
I have my phone. I have my car, my
truck. I guess that'll have to work. And
at the time I didn't I was in between I
just left my law firm where I was a
partner.
And to nobody cuz I wanted to start my
own law firm. So I didn't even have an
office.
So that's why I was first in my my
truck. But I looked up all the stuff of
having the best lighting. Yeah, actually
actually I lived there. Actually that's
that was my home. Congrats y'all. Y'all
are in my living room. That's actually
part of my story my origin story was
homeless.
>> Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Thankfully no.
Yeah.
And it was just the I couldn't make it
in the house cuz
kids and noise and No, I'm not going to
do that. And I wasn't I didn't have an
office to do anything. So I just stuck
with the car and away it went.
>> Wow, and it became what it was.
>> And now it became what it was. If you
enjoyed that clip and want to see the
rest of the conversation, you can click
right here. Or if you want to see the
latest episode of the Jefferson Fisher
podcast, click right here and I'll meet
you there.